the electoral college has done its
constitutional duty confirming that joe
biden will be our next president and in
a speech last night the president-elect
said the rule of law had prevailed
he received 306 electoral votes that is
the exact same number that president
trump called a landslide just four years
ago
nicole killian now reports
president-elect joe biden
celebrated his electoral college victory
and praised the estimated 155 million
americans who were determined to have
their voices heard this election now
ranks as the clearest demonstration
of the true will of the american people
mr biden skewered president trump's
exhaustive attempts to overturn the
election results
attempts that have been unsuccessful
president trump was
denied no course of action he wanted to
take
he took his case to republican governors
and republican secretary of state as he
criticized many of them
to republican state legislatures to
republican appointed judges at every
level
the president-elect also sharply
criticized republicans
including the 17 attorneys general and
126 house members who supported a
lawsuit aimed at overturning the
election results in four key states
it's a position so extreme we've never
seen it before
a position that refused to respect the
will of the people
refused to respect the rule of law and
refused to honor our constitution
mr biden spoke about the threats
election officials faced across the
country
it is my sincere hope we never again
see anyone subjected to the kind of
threats and abuse we saw
in this election it's simply
unconscionable
legislative offices in michigan were
closed yesterday amid threats of
violence
and state police had to block a group of
pro-trump supporters from entering the
capitol
but the process went on the electors
have unanimously cast
16 votes for joseph r biden
as the president continued false claims
of massive fraud
more republicans acknowledged the
president-elect
it's time for everybody to move on
russian president vladimir putin is now
the latest foreign leader to formally
congratulate president-elect biden on
his victory after
weeks of holding out until the results
were finalized
today mr biden travels to georgia to
campaign for two democrats in runoff
races
that will decide control of the senate
anthony nicole thank you